Hi, my name's Austin Chau.
I work on the Calendar
Date API team.
The Calendar Data API, is the
API that exposes the data of
your Google calendar account.
With the API, you can do
things like creating events,
searching for events, or even
create a whole new calendar
program automatically.
Today, I am going to go over
how to get started using
JavaScript Client Library to
talk to the Calendar Data API.
I'll also be showing a demo of
the new interactive developer
guide that I developed.
This new developer guide lets
you play with the code right
in the browser.
So it's a great learning tool
for you to start learning how
to use the client library.
The JavaScript Client Library
is the latest client library
that we have added to our list
of client libraries that we
officially support, which
includes Java, CSharp, PHP,
and Phython.
But the JavaScript Client
Library is particularly useful,
because it allows you to easily
integrate with the HTML and
there is no service side
dependency.
The JavaScript Client Library
also has the building
technology that allows cross-
domain communication, meaning
that you can now use JavaScript
to perform not only
re-operation, but also write.
Using the JavaScript Client
Library, it's very easy.
I'm going to show you the few
steps you need to do to set up
your code to start using it.
Step 1: You have to sign up
for a developer key. You do
that by going to this website.
Step 2: You need to include
the client library loader on
your website by placing this
script included with
your developer key.
Step 3: You need to upload an
image to the same domain where
the JavaScript Code is going
to be. This image doesn't have
to be visible.
As you can see, I'm positioning
it far off the page.
This is needed for
cross-domain
communication purposes.
Step 4: You need to use the
loader to load in the
JavaScript Client Library.
Step 5: You now need to set
the callback function to be
called when the library is
loaded and ready to go.
Step 6: Inside of the callback
function, you first need to check if the
user has logged in.
If not, you need to redirect
the user to the Google account
page to log in.
The user will then be returned
back to your page when
they are authenticated.
Now you are ready to use the
JavaScript Client Library to
make calls to play with
the calendar data API.
Now let's go to the
"Interactive Developer Guide."
You can access this by going
to this address.
The interactive developer
guide looks like a normal
developer guide with sample
code, demonstrating the common
used cases that you can
perform using the API.
But unlike the normal
developer guide, you can now
modify the source code using
the build-in text editor and
execute a code right
out of the browser.
This is a fun and intuitive
way to learn as you get to
immediately see the results of
the action you just performed.
So let's take a look at some
of the sample codes and we'll
try to execute it.
So let's run this sample code
and see what happens.
The snippet you just executed
retrieved a list of all your
calendars and printed
out the titles.
You can pull up the embedded
version of Google calendar to
verify that these are all the
calendars that belong to you.
Now let's take a look at the
code to see how this is done.
First you have to create calendar
service object and you have to pass
in your application name.
Then you have to specify the
"feedURL," where this request
will be sent to.
And we are using
the "allcalendar" feed.
Then you have to define
your callback function.
So inside a function, we are
just peering through the list
of calendars you have and
printing out it's title.
We are using the print
function, which is a
convenience method that we
provide in this
developer guide.
And then you also have to
create a callback function
for your "error handling."
And now we are just outputting
the error message to the
"Output" tab.
And finally, you have to
submit this request to the
server by calling the
"getALLCalendarsFeed" through
your calendar service object
by passing your "feedURL,"
your "callback" and your
"error callback."
So let's modify the code to
something different.
Let's add some code to print
out the time zone off
your calendar.
You can easily do that by
going into a text editor
and changing the code.
And now let's run this code.
You'll see you have to count
the title and the time zone
and output it.
Ok. Reading data from your
calendars is fun, but its more
interesting to write data
to calendars.
So let's create an event to
your Google calendar account.
First you have to create a
service object again.
And now you have to specify
a different URL to do
event creation.
And this is the URL we are
going to use, the
"private/full" URL.
And now you have to create an
MDB object to represent this
new event.
And we set the title to
"youtube video shoot."
To associate time with an
event, you have to create a
"When object."
Then we have to set a start
and end time of the
"When object" using the
daytime strain.
And here we are, specifying
the start time to be today
at 9:00 AM.
And we specify the stop time
at today...10:00 AM.
And then we set the
time to the "When object."
And then you add the
"When object" to the event.
And you also have to specify
the callback function to let
you know when
the event is created.
And you have to specify the
"error handling method" if
they are any errors happening.
And finally you have to submit
this request to the server by
calling the
"insert event method."
And let's run this code.
And let's take a look
at this data calendar.
And there it is.
I hope you have an idea of how
easy it is to use the
JavaScript Client Library.
The interactive developer
guide has many other samples
that demonstrate other
features of Calendar Data API.
So I encourage you to go check
it out and go play with that.
For more resources, you can
visit the Calendar Data API
home page on "code.google.com."
Thank you. Have fun coding.